Ok so season 4 of Cobra Kai delivered on so
many levels and I loved seeing another All
Valley Championships as well as the paths
we followed to get there.
Whether it was Miguel's big spinal injury
recovery, Hawks return after having been cut
down a peg or two, Tory and her troubled personal
life or the introduction of Kenny the season
was one of the strongest we've had so far.
But what happens from here on out?
Well that's what we're gonna be discussing
in this video as we go through the biggest
theories for the future of the show.
If this is your first time here then welcome
to the Heavy Spoilers show, I'm your host
Paul aka the guy who never backs out like
Miguel, now let's get into the breakdown.
Ok, so the season ended with Silver framing
Kreese for the violent assault on Stinkray.
We learned that Silver made ol' Stinky tell
the police that it was in fact Kreese that
smashed his face in like you should smash
that like button in order to let him rejoin
Cobra Kai.
The police turned up to take Kreese away and
he didn't exactly do himself any favours by
hitting one of the officers.
Towards the end of the series, we saw Kreese
seemed to change his ways and he actually
started developing some feelings and emotions
towards others.
Kreese was becoming a changed man and not
only had he started dropping the 'show no
mercy' side of the slogan but he probably
also wouldnt be feeding any pet mice named
fluffles to cobras in future.
This seemed to really aggravate Silver and
his big plan was already in motion which we
discovered was to develop and expand Cobra
Kai.
If you cast your mind back to the ending of
Karate Kid 3 then you may remember that he
wanted to do this throughout the valley but
the defeat by Daniel and probably poor critical
scores at the time stopped it dead in it's
tracks.
I can imagine moving forward we will see his
plans being put into effect with Silver beginning
to open new branches, and being the big bad
guy once more, however, I can't see it lasting
too long once the truth is out about Kreese
and his wrongful imprisonment.
Beyond that it would be great to see Silvers
original protege Mike Barnes turn up at some
point to get Silver out of trouble.
Silver did say that he was reaching out to
others and if he's gonna be opening up several
new franchises then he'll need Karate experts
he trusts to help set them up.
Barnes was one of the biggest bad guys in
the original trilogy and seeing them team
up again would be a great.
The way these relationships change quicker
than a season of Love Island, you never know
whos gonna team up next, but I think we will
be due another big threat in the future.
At some point I think we will go on to see
Stingray reveal the truth about what happened
and this will, in turn, lead to Kreese being
released and Silver being banged up instead,
halting his development of the Cobra Kai brand.
I think we could see a big change in Kreeses's
mindset as he clearly started to have some
regrets over his treatment of Johnny over
the years, revealing that he saw him as a
son more than anything else.
This could possibly lead to the making of
the peace between the pair and a potential
union on the cards.
As we know that the structure of the show
kind of repeats these cycles of making up
and breaking up quite regularly.
I'd love to see the three sides in Season
5 be made up of Silver and Barnes, Kreese
and Johnny and of course Daniel and Chozen.
We could also see Stingray return once this
has all taken place and rejoin the Cobra Kai
ranks once more under the new Kreese and Johnny
after the pair regain control.
I'm not sure what the future holds for Eagle
Fang as they also lost the competition alongside
Miyagi Do, which meant they both had to cease
from operating as Dojos.
Whether this deal will hold up or not is another
thing especially with the match-fixing and
surrounding scandal.
With Chozen being brought in it is also possible
that Daniel may find a loophole and that they'll
be able to have him as the dojo head as he
was never part of any of the others.
Another factor we need to throw into the mix
is the fact that Tory overheard Silver bribing
the All Valley referee.
I think this could all come out and just pile
on top of Silver and his impending prosecution
for the assault of Stingray.
We also know that Tory had been teasing with
the idea of trying to make up with Sam, but
Sam wasn't having any of it and always reacted
by insulting and shutting her down constantly.
Maybe this could be the thing to unite them,
once she comes clean about the fight fixing
scandal, we could potentially see Tory ditching
Cobra Kai and joining Daniel and Sam.
This is all just theories right now though
but I think this could be a nice way for the
story to develop.
I also think Tory will tell Robbie, and he
will be stuck having to choose what to do.
We saw Robbie and Johnny making up at the
end of the series and it would be great to
see father and son back together, fighting
alongside each other.
The series closed out with Daniel visiting
Mr Miyagi's grave, explaining how he tried
his best to follow the right path but it wasn't
enough.
He talks about needing to change and go on
the offence to take down Cobra Kai.
As he asks for help the camera spins to reveal
Chozen standing by his side at Miyagi's grave.
The pair agree to work together to take down
Cobra Kai once and for all.
We were first re-introduced to Chozen back
in Season 3, as we learned that Daniel believed
he knew everything there was to know that
Miyagi had taught him, until Chozen showed
him there were still some secrets.
This is where we learned Miyagi passed on
a scroll to Chozen containing this new technique,
Chozen then demonstrated this technique on
Daniel and paralysed his arm.
In Season 4 we see as LaPusso himself discovers
this scroll in Daniels Dojo, which could be
some serious foreshadowing on the horizon.
Daniel also used some of the techniques against
Johnny and I think they're being dotted throughout
the seasons to potentially build towards their
usage in the future.
Going forward I believe we will see Chozen
and Daniel uniting and changing the ways of
the Miyagi Do to incorporate a new more balanced
style, now covering offence as well as defence.
We can see that this is something that Daniel
has struggled to come to terms with throughout
the series as he has been so stuck in his
ways, but in a flashback we saw as Miyagi
told him in time he would adapt and create
his own style.
So, I think we will see the two sides, the
offensive style being brought in by Chozen
whilst Daniel adapts his more defensive approach
to enhance his game.
Now, who they go on to face is all a bit up
in the air at the moment, but Im guessing
it will still be a Silver led Cobra Kai until
he is brought to justice.
Now towards the end of the final episode we
also discover that Miguel has gone AWOL like
Johnnys dad did when he popped out to get
a pack of smokes.
He is actually heading off to Mexico City
on the last bus outta town and where we go
from here we don't know.
Now In my ending explained I did say that
this may have been done to free up Xolo Maridueña's
schedule so that he could go off to film Blue
Beetle.
However as many of you pointed out, Season
5 has actually already been filmed and therefore
his appearance won't be affected my scheduling.
However, I don't accept that I ever get things
wrong and I don't have any weaknesses so say
goodbye to your favourite mouse.
Now we learn from Carmen that Miguels father
is a pretty bad guy who doesn't actually know
he has a son.
So this doesn't really bode well for Miguel
going in search of the father he has never
met, nor does his
father know Miguel exists.
I think this is only gonna end badly with
Miguel returning rejected by his father, back
to the arms of his makeshift one aka Johnny
Lawrence.
However I don't think that we will be back
to square one and he will likely be annoyed
that Carmen didn't tell his father about him.
In this season, though she and Johnny Told
Miguel about their relationship they did keep
it from him for some time and coupled in with
the dad thing it could be the straw that broke
the camels back.
It would be nice to see Johnny and Miguel
make up and I think Johnny is due a bit of
good fortune as he has definitely changed
his ways a lot since the series began.
As for who Miguels father is I don't think
there's really been any evidence to support
him being Silver like I know a lot of you
in the comments are saying.
Though that would be a Dart Vader Level twist
that would be worthy of the Maury show I don't
think it's likely.
Carmen ended up attending the All Valley and
in doing this she would've at least seen Silver
and therefore would likely recognise him.
Also though we aren't 100% what happened with
Silver after Karate Kid 3, I doubt he went
to Mexico City.
Judging by his Mansion he likely just stayed
in the US and continued to build his Empire.
Now people are also saying that Mike Barnes
might be Miguel's father too.
I'm still kinda in the camp that he has some
relation to Tory and when you think about
it we still know very little about her.
She just showed up one day being a highly
advanced fighter and I think it would be a
pretty big reveal if it turned out that Barnes
was her day.
Now, a part of the season which I loved was
the scenes between Kenny and Anthony.
Backed up by his group of nerdy mates, Anthony
picks on Kenny from day one after seeing him
dancing at the bus stop.
The two both have an interest in the same
girl and LaPusso, simply cant handle it, as
deep down he's still that spoilt little brat
we saw in earlier seasons.
Anthony continues to push Kenny to breaking
point until he decides he needs to stand up
for himself and we watch as Kenny joins Cobra
Kai.
In doing so he changes drastically into a
cold blooded, killing machine that is the
master of stealth takedowns.
In the final scene between the pair we see
Anthony try to speak to Kenny in the locker
room and from this we witness how much the
latter has changed.
He's gone from being the shy nervous kid he
once was to somebody with Cobra Kai venom
surging through their veins.
I loved seeing him slamming LaPusso into the
lockers and piling into him but it just goes
to cement the effect the Sensei's have had
on their students.
I think this rivalry will continue on in to
the next season and we will potentially see
a face off between Anthony and Kenny, however.
We're back in the same cycle where one person
bullies one character, that character becomes
a ninja and retaliates and then that other
person has to join a dojo so that they can
at least keep up.
Unlike the constant switching sides though
I just can't see Anthony rebelling against
his father and joining another dojo.
Sam has stuck it out with her dad and add
to this we saw Anthony discover the scrolls
for the paralysing pressure punch moves which
we mentioned earlier.
Who knows, Anthony might even study these
and it could come into play against Kenny
next time.
Either way I'm betting they go head to head
at the next all valley but which dojo goes
against Cobra Kai is gonna be interesting
to see.
Now I'd of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let me
know.
We're running a competition right now and
giving away 3 copies of an MCU Boxset of your
choice on the 30th of January.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it's definitely
worth checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace